sometimes I read [ __ ]
three-month time I said so I talked
about AMA I'm gonna make a conscious
effort to not talk about pubes and share
all the time but that's the brand though
I wish I'd never seen musk upon these
faces voices ruined for me know what was
my apply atlas tweet think it was like I
understand it must be so difficult to
get AB or not every time you hear my
songs I get us to be outlaw a [ __ ]
law I got a lot of tweets about the way
I look right
some people are nicer than others a lot
of people say look like as I see look
like my cloth petite smiley that old guy
who eat that pin you know that that I
get that same to me on on a daily basis
I was at an Edinburgh at the weekend and
a girl came up to me and said listen and
I know what people see on a any stuff
but that's the thing a really
good-looking yeah what a lot of people
see it online leave that [ __ ] bad
just see you think I'm nice I'll look
nice he'll look fine my dad asked me
what mdme was and before I could answer
my mum chained them with and all that
says my mum chained them with seeing his
mixed martial arts she wasn't in all my
mom knew MDMA was I'd be worried but he
did have three kids mum good off again
it was a [ __ ] bang on it weekend I
found some planes should come with
warnings because I was full-on cry miser
at something I think there's a flight to
New York where I was already quite
feeling quite a indefinite before I went
on a plane and I was fill on having a
breakdown but this particular film was
Benjamin Button and there I don't know
what better would have been crying uh
maybe it's a bad way [ __ ] becomes a
baby and dies so that is me saying weird
that everyone loves bummed so much but
that's where the pure lives look as if I
sell it and as Shepherd but it as with
the pillows the food does live in the
bomb there's all rap songs about eating
the cake which eating the cake as eating
a bottom scrap scanning an ass so yeah
that's captioners
it's definitely about the cold saw this
on my face I've got a cultural know but
it's something about still got a cold
chill on my face but it hasn't me this
way to my genitals just yet
hippies hanging about my left foot away
on the more say Muhammad Yunus was just
yet yet evil but rest assured stell no
saying of anything on my genitals at all
I haven't done the touch of anyone and
quite something quite well acquainted
with this little guy but still no
genital herpes
thank you very much less afraid he's a
federal child came out the first time
since November 2011 that the top two
sports are held by Scott jacks
Calvin Harris and OSHA filed their
ballot for number one that's the first
of all very cool thing to read and for
me but then I did see that was
Scotland's biggest export Cowen Harris
goes up against Scotland's biggest waste
lane me to absolute titans of Scottish
industry coming head to head and their
yeah it was it was murder and him so
last day of the Great Scott Awards I
went to the bathroom as then what harm I
went to the toilets I was I mean I don't
know the captioners but I was at the
toilets Hubbell of poo the guy who does
my PR and Scotland came up and says
Louis we need you downstairs for a
minute I said that very hastily wiped my
ass I got down and I had to go straight
up and do a speech I said something
about to be honest I'm just a bit
worried that masks are still kicked and
shades and it was I will straight back
to that bathroom that was in a wad
winner well the three more shoes was in
your tois one of them is gonna be [ __ ]
one's gonna be [ __ ] and one of them's
gonna be again oh no it buzzing or
because I'm absolutely buzzing to tell
you right I'm never actually that puzzle
it's just something that you see excited
that's a Tzadik sofa number one [ __ ]
I was right I've got number one rate at
least yeah lovely that's that's app for
that but thank you very much for having
us in um thank you very much for
watching me and regale my absolute
[ __ ] incessant
[ __ ] from the internet hope you've
enjoyed this please don't judge me
bye
Lock this again not just IT demanded it
IT denied that you protect your palm
okay